bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
sur sociaux de gosse
[Musique]
je suis très heureuse de vous retrouver
aujourd'hui sur ma chaîne youtube
d'autant plus que j'ai une annonce à
vous faire j'avais envie de trouver un
nouveau projet pour cette chaîne youtube
pour lui donner un nouvel élan et c'est
chose faite puisque j'ai eu l'idée d'une
série de vidéos cette série de vidéos
elle va s'étendre tout au long de
l'année scolaire en parallèle de mes
autres vidéo habituels et je ne veux pas
faire durer le suspense plus longtemps
je vais vous proposer une série de
vidéos qui vont permettre de plonger
avec moi dans une soupe branche de la
sociologie qui est la sociologie des
mouvements sociaux alors chaque vidéo
reposera sur l'étude de cas d'une
mobilisation d'un mouvement social en
particulier en france ou à l'étranger
mais le but sera pas uniquement de vous
faire une espèce de résumé historique de
ce mouvement social en fait l'objectif
de cette série vidéo ça va être de voir
le regard que les sciences sociales
posées ont posé sur les mouvements
sociaux en question en fait l'idée c'est
de montrer comment les mouvements
sociaux ont interagi avec l'université
jusqu'à permettre de former d
épistémologie nouvelle l'épistémologie
c'est un domaine philosophique qui
analyse en faites de manière critique
toutes les disciplines scientifiques
dans la manière dont elles produisent de
la connaissance donc on la manière dont
on produit le savoir étudier
l'épistémologie se permet donc en fait
d'engager une réflexion sur la
connaissance sur le savoir en se
demandant par exemple qui produit le
savoir dans une société dans quel
contexte avec quelles méthodes et ses
voiles a donc je vais essayer de lier en
fait la sociologie de la connaissance
les questions épistémologiques et des
études de cas très précise des
mouvements sociaux pour vous faire voir
un panel assez large de différents
éléments de sociologie des mouvements
sociaux cette série j'ai décidé de
l'appeler la sociologie en mouvement
j'espère que ce sera un rendez vous que
vous intéressera qui vous fera découvrir
des mouvements sociaux sous un autre
regard que celui de l'actualité ou de
l'histoire donc pour cet épisode pilote
je vous propose de voyager à travers
l'histoire de la sociologie des
mouvements sociaux pour que vous
compreniez un petit peu dans quel
contexte est née cette branche de la
sociologie par quelle grande période
scientifique allait passer et voir un
petit peu niveau épistémologique comment
ça évolue c'est donc parti pour un très
rapide aperçu de la sociologie des
mouvements sociaux alors pour commencer
un petit point des finitions en
répondant à la question de qu'est-ce
qu'un mouvement social selon le
dictionnaire de sociologie de raymond
boudon un mouvement social c'est une
entreprise collective qui vise à établir
un nouvel ordre de vie ou à résister
contre l'effondrement d'un ordre de vie
et précise également qu'un mouvement
social n'est possible qu'avec la
mobilisation des acteurs et des actrices
qui le compose ensuite qu'est ce que la
sociologie des mouvements sociaux la
sociologie des mouvements sociaux c'est
une branche une sous catégorie de la
sociologie qui tente de répondre à la
question de savoir pourquoi un moment
donné les hommes et les femmes se
rebelle pour reprendre le titre d'un
ouvrage de tiger dont on parlera plus
tard mais au delà de la question de
savoir pourquoi on se mobilise il ya
aussi la question de savoir comment au
sein de quelle structure dans quel
contexte autour de quelles questions et
c'est à toutes ces questions que la
sociologie mouvements sociaux que se
propose de répondre le but de la
sociologie des mouvements sociaux
s'étant fait d'étudier les mouvements
sociaux existants donc des mobilisations
collectives pour mieux comprendre les
enjeux sociétaux qu'ils cristallisent le
sociologue eric neveux va même plus loin
en nous expliquant que l'analyse des
mouvements sociaux reste un terrain de
choix pour appréhender tant les attentes
nouvelles que les désillusions que
suscite le modèle démocratique tel qu'il
s'incarne voilà pour les définitions je
vous propose donc maintenant d'explorer
avec moi l'histoire de la sociologie des
mouvements sociaux la sociologie des
mouvements sociaux s est développée dès
la fin du 19ème siècle et tout au long
du xxème siècle en parallèle notamment
les premiers mouvements ouvriers ensuite
on va s'intéresser à un nouvel élan qu'a
connue cette discipline aux états unis
et en france dans les années 60 70 du
fait de la très vive actualité politique
de cette époque et enfin j'aborderai
avec vous le tournant radical capri la
sociologie des mouvements sociaux au
début du 21ème siècle alors dans un
premier temps je vais vous parler des
prémices de la sociologie des mouvements
sociaux c'est à dire de la fin du 19ème
à la première moitié du 20e siècle
ça ne fait de mystère pour personne mais
la paternité de la sociologie des
mouvements sociaux est très souvent
attribué à carme marque en effet c'est
l'analyse marxiste de la société
industrielle qui reposent sur la lutte
des classes entre bourgeois et
prolétaires qui donne ses lettres de
noblesse à la sociologie des mouvements
sociaux en effet marc santré le rôle
essentiel du mouvement ouvrier dans la
structuration de la société industrielle
l'idée c'est donc de nous montrer qu'un
mouvement social une action collective
peut aboutir à l'institution d'un dans
ce renouveau d'ailleurs de très nombreux
chercheurs politologue économistes
philosophes sociologues se sont
intéressés à la révolution prolétarienne
en russie puis aux premières années de
l'urss mais avec la seconde guerre
mondiale et l'avènement de la guerre
froide on s'intéresse finalement de
moins en moins aux mouvements sociaux
pourtant dans les années 60 70 et un
véritable retour en force de l'analyse
sociologique des mouvements sociaux du
fait d'une actualité politique
extrêmement vive on a par exemple civil
rights movement aux états unis qui est
très structurée mais aussi à des
mouvements étudiants comme les 68
féministes écologistes ou vouliez même
parfois ouvriers immigrés au même moment
des grands mouvements d'indépendance
dans notre pays donc c'est un moment où
l'actualité est riche et en fait ça
pousse les chercheurs à s'intéresser de
nouveau augmentatio et à tenter de
nouvelles formes de théorisation en
france le chercheur alain touraine
analyse d'ailleurs l'arrivée de ces
nouveaux mouvements sociaux comme signe
du passage d'une société industrielle à
une société post industrielle
sauf que dans les années 60 70 ce qui
domine le champ des sciences sociales ce
sont la psychanalyse et l'économie
pendant quelques décennies la sociologie
et vous man sociaux va donc se
structurer au prisme de la psychanalyse
et de l'économie les deux courants que
sont donc la psychanalyse et l'économie
vont aboutir à des mouvements parfois un
petit peu contradictoires au sein des
sciences sociales pour expliquer les
mouvements sociaux aux états unis il ya
une branche très nettement inspiré de la
psychanalyse qui se développe avec un
ouvrage fondateur qui est pourquoi les
hommes se rebelle de teddy que pourquoi
les hommes ces rebelles est un ouvrage
qui est très clairement inspiré de la
psychologie des foules de gustave lebon
est comme son nom indique la psychologie
des foules ne va pas forcément aller
vers une analyse sociologique c'est à
dire les causes sociales d'une
mobilisation mais plutôt se centrer sur
l'individu et sur les émotions sur les
mécanismes psychologiques qui pousse les
hommes et les femmes à se mobiliser ce
lien qui est fait entre psychologie et
sociologie donne naissance à ce qu'on
appelle les théories du comportement
collectif les théories du comportement
collectif sociologie met l'accent sur
donc des données psychologiques tels que
par exemple la frustration pour
expliquer le passage d'un mécontentement
individuelle à une action collective
dans plus ou moins le même temps on a
une autre branche de la sociologie des
mouvements sociaux qui se développe et
qui est très inspirée par les théories
économiques donc toujours aux états unis
on a des théories qui sont en fait
inspirée de raisonnements économiques
comme les théories de la mobilisation
des ressources ou les théories de
l'action collective qui vont avoir
recours à des outils à des concepts
économiques pour expliquer pourquoi les
hommes et les femmes se mobilisent les
chercheurs qui s'inscrivent dans cette
branche de la sociologie des mouvements
sociaux vont donc avoir recours à des
concepts tels que le calcul rationnel ou
encore l'idée du passager clandestin
pour expliquer des comportements
individuels qui aboutissent à la
formation de mouvements sociaux mais il
est vrai que les théories qu'elle soit
celle inspirée de la psychanalyse ou
inspirés des réflexions économiques sont
finalement un petit peu maintenant
passée de mode même si la plupart des
chercheurs continuent de s'inscrire dans
une perspective critique par rapport à
ces théories il est vrai que
quand on regarde par exemple les sujets
de thèses qui sont les plus choisis ou
les articles qui sont produits par
rapport à des mouvements sociaux en
cours on s'inscrit dans une nouvelle
phase a qui y est donc un grand tournant
qu'a pris la sociologie des mouvements
sociaux au début des années 2000 mais
dès le début des années 2000 on a une
nouvelle tendance qui marquent
l'histoire de la sociologie des
mouvements sociaux en fait depuis le
début des années 2000 les sciences et
notamment les sciences humaines et
sociales sont parcourus par une pensée
qui vient remettre en cause la notion
même d'objectivité on a donc un intérêt
nouveau pour le subjectif et l'objectif
ication du subjectif donc les mouvements
sociaux ne sont plus forcément vus comme
des grandes théories économiques gravé
dans le marbre avec des données
objectives ni comme un fait qu'on peut
réduire au niveau individuel par des
explications psychologiques mais on met
plutôt au coeur du processus les
explications politiques sociaux
économiques politiques sur les
conditions qui pousse un moment un
groupe d'individus à se mobiliser et
surtout on s'intéresse de plus en plus à
ce label la sociologie du militantisme
donc là il ya tout cet intérêt pour le
vécu militants par exemple ça va revenir
à mettre au coeur de sa méthodologie des
entretiens longs avec des militants pour
comprendre comment ils ont construit
leur parcours mutants comment ils sont
passés du citoyen lambda aux citoyens
activistes et pouvoir en fait comment se
construit petit à petit un mouvement
social qui ne va pas nécessairement
avoir une éruption mais bien sûr
construire au sein de structures par
exemple d'un parti d'une association
pour autant un événement qui est venu
bouleverser la sociologie des mouvements
sociaux c'est par exemple en france le
mouvement des vigiles et jaune puisqu'il
n'est pas de structures préexistantes
donc il a aussi maintenant de nouvelles
analyses qui prennent en compte le rôle
des réseaux sociaux dans le militantisme
et dans l'avènement des mouvements
sociaux à l'ère d'internet donc comme
vous voyez la sociologie des mouvements
sociaux a très nettement évolué de sa
fondation à nos jours et a été traversé
par des mouvements qui révèle les
grandes tendances scientifiques de
l'époque qu'elle a traversé ce sera tout
pour cet épisode pilote de la série la
sociologie en mouvement j'espère que
vous serez au rendez vous pour le
premier épisode de cette série qui sera
consacré d'ailleurs 'l'annonce à un
mouvement social français d'ailleurs je
vous laisse un petit indice tout de
suite
en attendant de vous retrouver dans une
prochaine vidéo je vous invite à vous
abonner à aller saint gemmes à cette
vidéo à la partager pour claire vivre
sociaux logos je vous remercie d'être de
plus en plus nombreux à me suivre sur
cette chaîne n'hésitez pas également à
l'émotion certes à g pour avoir mon
quotidien de doctorante en sociologie
sur ce je vous souhaite une très bonne
journée et je vous dis à très bientôt
sur sociaux de gosse
[Musique]